hey what is up everybody it's annamac
here for
anime uproar and today i will be talking
about the tragic sacrifice that we just
witnessed
in black clover as well as the real
truth
about devil magic a truth that is
finally being revealed
now that the devil queen megicula has
taken
center stage this truth has massive
implications for
asta and for all forms of devil magic
things are changing extremely quickly in
black clover so let's get into it
if you enjoyed the black lover content
on this channel and you want us to keep
it going just leave a quick like and
comment
it only takes a second but it helps a
lot and if you're new to anime out pro
or maybe you watch our videos but you
just haven't taken the time to subscribe
yet do me a favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit
that notification bell to turn on all
notifications
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
animeopror finally this video will
contain black lover manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned
the story picks up right after megikula
completely turned the tables on our
heroes back in the previous chapter
noel's spirit dive ran out gaia was
seriously wounded by devil or pachika
and megicula's curse magic was
successfully negating
all the spells that were thrown her way
including of course
ryl's twilight of valhalla and noel's
sea dragon's roar
in fact mkikula's decaying world has now
spread
throughout the entire surrounding area
which means that no one will be able to
help
noel and the others i mean i doubt
that's actually true because
osta's anti-magic probably can't
penetrate decaying world
it's just how anti-magic works but the
point still stands
magikala is now in complete control of
this entire battlefield
and things don't look good for our
heroes asta will probably be able to
help once he
shows up but when is he actually going
to show up that's the big question
megikula is definitely not the only
threat inside the spade kingdom castle
right now we have all those lesser
devils running around
we have the cliff off gate we have
morris we have xenon
so yeah asta may be preoccupied dealing
with all of that for some time
noel and undine then turned their
attention to gaia
who is still in the process of being
shish kebabbed by
devil loro he is bleeding from his mouth
which means that his lungs have probably
suffered serious damage
and you can't help but think that this
might really be the end
for gaia but if this is the end for gaia
he refuses to go out without a fight
gaia uses his lightning magic to
temporarily
immobilize devil loro without actually
hurting her
and he then proceeds to make his move
perhaps the final move that he is
ever going to make as gaia begins to
move
we see a quick flashback in which a
young gaia dedicates himself to
protecting his country
the hard kingdom and its queen he loves
his country and his people so
he is loyal to his queen and he has
committed his life
to that cause however gaia
always blamed himself for the fact that
loro was cursed by megicula
about a year earlier after that tragic
incident
gaia prostrated himself before loro and
apologized declaring himself
unfit to be a spirit guardian but
being the kind and compassionate person
that she is
loro didn't blame gaia at all in fact
she thanks gaia for saving her life
because if he hadn't been there she
wouldn't have just been cursed she would
have been dead
not only that but the people of the
heart kingdom were saved
thanks to gaia and that is the most
important thing of all
loro always puts the people of her
kingdom first and that is why her
current situation
is so tragic now that she is being
controlled by megicula
she is being forced to do the exact
opposite of what she really wants to do
and gaia simply can't allow this
terrible
situation to continue in that moment
gaia admits that even more than his
country
what he truly wished for was to protect
loro he might have started out as a
patriotic spirit guardian who was loyal
to the heart kingdom and
its queen but eventually he developed
feelings for loro as a person
not just as the queen and so his
priority became
to protect her to me personally this is
confirmation that gaia is in love with
loro
and that he would do anything for her
not just out of some sense of loyalty to
his queen
but because she is the woman he loves
gaia refuses to allow
loro to die and he refuses to allow
himself to be killed by loro
because he knows that this would break
her heart so instead of waiting to die
from the injuries inflicted upon him by
loro
gaia decides to willingly sacrifice his
own life before he can die from the
injuries
he forces his way past the immobilized
loro
causing even greater injury to himself
in the process and he turns
all the remaining life force in his body
into
magic gaia then uses all of that magic
magic that he is sacrificing his very
life
to create to attack megikula with one
epic
ultimate lightning magic spell the spell
is so quick and so strong that even
decaying world cannot
negate it and it shoots through megicula
and straight through the entire spade
kingdom palace
the spell manages to disconnect megicula
from her host
vanica as vanica's body falls to the
ground
gaia is seemingly able to severely
damage mkikula's imperfect
form although this comes at a great cost
to gaia himself
and i will talk about this in a little
bit noel sees what just happened
and she also rushes into action she
plans to use what's left of her
saint stage power to finish makikula off
but then something happens something
that stops noel
in her tracks as gaia stands there
on the verge of death his body seemingly
crumbling as if it had been reduced to
nothing but an empty shell
a large winged shape begins to emerge
from the dust and smoke we don't get to
see the shape clearly
at least not in this chapter but it
looks like gaia's sacrifice
may have been in vain by the looks of
that
dark silhouette megikula has not
been defeated in fact if the second
sacrifice manika is now
dead as a result of gaia's attack
megikula may have been able to manifest
more fully into this world after all
the more sacrifices are made the closer
she comes to manifesting her perfect
form
in this world so unfortunately gaia's
attack
may have allowed makikula to unlock a
new form that is even stronger than
before
and on that ominous note the chapter
comes to an end
whoa what a tragic chapter especially
that end
which seems to suggest that gaia's truly
epic sacrifice might have been for
nothing this man pushed through the
enormous amount of pain that he was
feeling
he poured every last ounce of his life
force into this one final attack
and he may now die with the knowledge
that he not only failed to defeat
megicula
but that he actually made her even
stronger by accident
whoa that is rough
that said though huge respect to gaia
for making such an incredible sacrifice
for the woman that he loves and of
course for the good of humanity as a
whole there's that as well
in my opinion he will die after this
i'm not sure in which chapter he will
die and nothing is for sure because this
is black clover and
magic is a thing but after all the build
up for this sacrifice
i don't think that gaia will live to see
the next
arc let me know if you guys agree down
in the comments below
is gaia going to die or is he going to
magically recover somehow
and if so how also i have to say that
megikula has really changed the entire
game in black clover since she first
appeared in the flesh and if she just
unlocked a new form as i think she might
have
then it is possible that we were all
wrong about asta and the true nature of
devil power
we know that liba is a lower ranked
devil but because he possesses the very
unique
anti-magic he and asta have been able to
do incredible things
even against highest ranked devils like
lilith
and nama but mkikula megikula seems to
be on a whole other level from
lilith and nama and if megikula
is this insanely powerful then the other
main devils like lucifer
are likely just as strong as her if not
even stronger
all this time i've just been assuming
that asta will use
anti-magic to take down all the devils
after all we've seen just how effective
anti-magic
is against the devils so of course asta
will be the one to take them down
but after megikula i am not so sure
if megikula can withstand gaia's
ultimate lightning magic attack that
required him to sacrifice his very life
then she will not be taken down easily
not even with anti-magic
now of course we don't know for sure
that magikala survived the attack
but from that winged silhouette at the
end of the chapter
it really seems like she has and when
you consider megicola's ability to
possess and manipulate loro
she could end up being an incredibly
difficult opponent
for asta the ability to possess asta's
allies like she is doing with loro
is going to make asta's job a lot more
difficult
not only is he going to have to fight
megicula but he will also have to fight
devil loro
and potentially other allies that
magikala manages to take possession of
and while he's fighting those allies he
will have to try not to hurt them now if
you combine
this possession ability with magikala's
other abilities
anti-magic alone may not cut it this
time around
asta may be about to meet his match
either in megicula
or in some other devils who are on
megicula's level such as
lucifer usually asta's anti-magic has
been his go-to solution for all of his
devil related problems but devils like
megikula seem to be on a whole different
level from
anything we've seen before don't forget
that this is megicula in her
imperfect form imagine how strong she
would be
once her fully perfected form manifests
that's hard to even imagine at this
point
definitely let me know what you guys
think are megicula and the other devils
on her level
too strong to be defeated through
anti-magic alone
and if so how do you think they will
ultimately be defeated
tabitha's go to solution is usually
really good teamwork
so maybe we are going to see that epic
noel asta team up
or maybe yami's dark magic is going to
play a role
later on i don't know but i can't wait
to find out how this unbelievably
awesome war arc ends if you enjoyed this
black clover video and you want to see
more in the future all you have to do is
leave a like and comment it only takes a
second but it helps with the youtube
algorithm
and if you're new to anime pro or maybe
you watch our videos but you just
haven't taken the time to subscribe yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting that bell and then selecting the
option that says all
if you don't do that you're still gonna
miss a ton of our videos even if you are
subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter and instagram
at animeopror i wanna give a big thank
you to all of our anime uproar
patrons for making videos like this one
possible
special thank you to alpha sigma he is
an absolute mad lad and disciple
of lord twego himself and i can't forget
all of our
the one tier patrons the ones who rise
above all
other clans including ingrata pate
heffel
algertol hirokami and water the toasted
chi the spike
emperor otaku spidey life canal tungsten
tarkis baked buddhist cody hebert
and monkey d quilly finally thank you
also to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh the
red haired raven
angel cruz rafindera very gucci alicia
octor
bonnie parks joy and garcia techno ted
fat boy games corey mcgowan and soul ray
slice and dice
if you enjoy our videos and you feel
that they provide value to you consider
supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patron exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you